revisite la langue française avec 700
nouvelles définitions justement lolo est
ce que tu peux me donner toi d'abord des
définitions sur plein de noms différents
c'est à dire tu nous as fait une
surprise puisqu'on m'a dit qu'ils
avaient préparé des définitions sur nos
chroniqueurs aujourd'hui on doit trouver
de qui il s'agit pour aller présenter
grâce à des définitions vas-y vas-y mais
faut pas de vie n'est pas ce que je dis
le nombre dans l'ordre quand tu veux pas
deviner par exemple eric naulleau la
définition c'est bon gars qui nous
explique le bon goût c'est l'abbé naïve
valérie bénaïm fille sciatique mais
droite c'est bien pour l'avenir
ce mignon on dirait pas du baffie oui
j'ai lu à l'aise à oxymore visuelle au
nez crochu à la voix nasillarde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
isabelle morini-bosc doublure officielle
de lady gaga
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jean michel maire toujours en ballotage
3 10e quand mes couilles
[Rires]
elie blonde platine qui aiment les
reflets auburn as exactement ça jane
kennedy ancien mannequin qui n'a pas
besoin de miroirs pour réfléchir au lieu
de leur mot à merde et grand sentimental
qui n'aiment que lui et je sais pas si
vous avez chez vous mais le loup c'est
très jeune il approuve mais pour lady
gaga et moi tes moyens c'est alors pour
financer ce cas de plus près c'est
vraiment un livreur qui passent plus de
temps à râler à la télé que dans les 1
bouteille
[Applaudissements]
sport et pour finir cyril hanouna
amateurs de tête de turc qui bosse fort
[Applaudissements]